well
hello how are you greetings andrés gonzález
with your brief informative news down
spanish his name is in custody this
morning after crashing his
all-terrain vehicle on christmas eve
yasmani brand new 26 years old faces a
charge of reckless driving
his sister  She was a passenger and lost
one of her arms but says her
brother doesn't deserve to be blamed for what
happened The Metropolitan Police are still
on the trail of the suspect who
caused the shooting inside the
restaurant in Chinatown Detectives to
watch Ryan Gaston Anderson, 23 years old
he shot chen jing wang inside the
restaurant where he worked he was
located near spring mountain view the
victim was shot 11 times and there is
hope for him to
survive tuesday development council
asian community will launch campaign
to raise funds for wang and his
family to  More details visit
if you had a natural Christmas tree
for these holidays and you don't know what to do
with it we recommend that you recycle
there are several locations in the valley where
you can deposit your tree make sure you
remove all the decorations for
all the details visit our
news now dotcom page the section in
Spanish and now we will now turn to
the weather forecast we will have some
odds  of rain for Monday
with a maximum of 52 degrees the
rain will last until Thursday with
temperatures that do not exceed 50
beautiful day the health andrés gonzález with
his brief informative of iu news now in
Spanish
[Music]